en plein coeur de New York ces grandes
tentes blanches des tonnes une mesure
d'urgence prise par la ville pour
accueillir les milliers de migrants qui
arrivent en bus du Texas depuis le mois
de mai
oui
envoie un bus remplis de migrants
l'endroit est surveillé 24 heures sur 24
la gare nationale des agents de firme
privée sont sur le qui-vive on protège
l'endroit des civils nous dit-on
Sylvina stérile et journaliste pour RFI
espagnol et rapporte quotidiennement sur
la crise migratoire
on voit tout sauf des migrants ditelles
l'endroit est froid peu accueillant
les médias ont eu accès une seule fois
des télévisions des téléphones et des
machines à laver sont disponibles pour
les nouveaux arrivants New York veut
remplir son devoir moral et veut
respecter la loi qui l'oblige à héberger
tous les citoyens de la ville
envoyez-moi vos fatiguez vos pauvres vos
portes qui aspirent à vivre libre Didas
statue de la Liberté
les voilà donc
les gens soient traités humainement
dit-il mais on ne se bouscule pas au
portillon pour accueillir les réfugiés
qui fait déjà face à une crise du
logement
car l'arrivée des migrants s'ajoute au
niveau record des 100 abris dans la
ville près de 64000 personnes sont sans
domicile fixe à New York le moratoire
pour empêcher les expulsions de
locataires durant la pandémie prend fin
sans compter l'inflation le coût
exorbitant des loyers qui dans certains
cas a augmenté de 35%. certains
locataires se retrouvent donc dans la
rue
la ville réclame près d'un milliard de
dollars du gouvernement fédéral et
déclare l'état d'urgence c'est donc ici
dans ce lieu hautement sécurisé que le
maire de New York espère installer 500
migrants mais déjà les critiques
affluent parce que c'est installation
est très loin du centre-ville
pour le moment les migrants sont
éparpillés à travers la ville dans des
hôtels comme yini son mari et ses deux
enfants qui sont arrivés de la ville
d'El Paso il y a une semaine et on vient
on a assez
situation politique au Venezuela est
difficile dit-elle la violence extrême
il quitte alors la ville de Victoria en
septembre pour entamer leur long périple
vers l'Eldorado américain ils ont
traversé la Colombie le Panama le
Nicaragua
le Guatemala il est parti dur dit-elle
puis le Mexique avant d'arriver à la
frontière américaine ils ont marché
parfois 12 heures par jour si ton nom ça
les autorités vénézuéliennes nous ont
dit si vous ne sortez pas voter nous
allons brûler vos maisons dit-elle ça a
été l'élément déclencheur pour partir
depuis 2015 7 millions de venezueliens
ont quitté leur pays
une fois sur place à New York
caritative catholique café les prend en
charge
[Musique]
on leur fournit différents services
d'Ital ils peuvent postuler pour des
assurances médicales une carte
d'identité de New York inscrire leurs
enfants à l'école voilà
mais ces réfugiés ballotté d'un état à
un autre son la cible des campagnes
électorales républicaines à deux
semaines des élections de mi-mandat on
parle de tente luxueuses pour ces
nouveaux arrivants alors que les
Américains peinent à s'en sortir avec
l'inflation
de drogue d'humains qui contrôlent nos
frontières du kerylake la candidate
républicaine en Arizona au poste de
gouverneur
on ne sait pas qui sont sur la chaîne
Fox on parle d'invasion de grands
remplacement de futurs électeurs
démocrates
ils utilisent des migrants pour marquer
des points
mais peu importe les tentes sont prêtes
à les accueillir avant l'hiver nous
dit-on
Marie veulent envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école et travailler le plus tôt
possible et surtout ne pas être un
fardeau pour le système
ici Radio-Canada New York